hallo mein name ist luca und wir machen
heute herein wahr oder falsch kurz dabei
geht es darum das deine aussage steht
und wir sagen ob das wahr oder falsch
ist faule eier schwimmen oben
träger dieses foul die schwimmen gar
nicht die spanische nationalhymne hat
keinen text hier haben wir kein geld für
den songwriter gehabt ich würde sagen
dass das einfach mal war es
ich glaube entweder spanien oder
portugal ihre wirklich keinen text die
kleine meerjungfrau findet man in
amsterdam was
ich kenne meerjungfrau mann und den gibt
es in spongebob am südpol kann man
polarlichter bestaunen ein
oder ich würde sagen einfach
nein weil ich glaube dass das nur am
nordpol oder also auf jeden fall nur im
nordischen ländern geht so es war in der
griechischen mythologie der bruder von
jupiter kommt egal woher soll ich so was
wissen pheromone ist die richtige
schreibweise für einen lockstoff das
stimmt
glaube ich istanbul ist die hauptstadt
der türkei acom ankara das kriege ich
wohl auch noch in einen hausarzt
bezeichnet man auch als dermatologe nein
ein dermatologe ist ein hautarzt kein
hausarzt voll dumm eigentlich dass
häuser ärzte brauchen der arc de
triomphe steht in paris
mit o geschrieben also ja der akte trier
steht auf jeden fall in paris
oder meine damit ein anderes denkmal ich
würde einfach mal sagen war denn viele
sind große fische nein
fische sind fische und delfine sind
säugetiere
das hat das hat überhaupt keinen sinn
ergeben luca frei lebende eisbären gibt
es nur am nordpol nein es gibt locker
auch irgendeinen eisbär irgendwo anders
auf der welt nicht eingesperrt ist
der mensch ist ein säugetier
decker
machen diese frage irgendeinen sinn nein
es gibt einen knochen namens amboss in
der nase acom zuvor hin weil die frage
der mensch ist ein säugetier ist weiß
jeder jedes lebewesen auf der welt weiß
dass der mensch ein solches und jetzt
amboss in der nase ich kenne nur ein
amboss von minecraft anbau von cannabis
ist in hessen legal falsch nirgendwo in
deutschland ist er
hab ich was verpasst das verstehe ich ja
auch nicht so richtig in deutschland ist
der anbau und der handel von cannabis
strikt verboten aber der konsum
es erlaubt das heißt theoretisch wenn
ich mit cannabis herumlaufen würde und
die polizei würde ankommen könnte ich
das einfach aufessen oder sehe ich das
falsch aber freunde keine macht den
drogen
die 13 ist eine primzahl ja
oder sein land in ostasien ich weiß auf
jeden fall dass es ein getränk namens
computer gibt
ich würde einfach mal sagen ene mene
miste es rappelt in der kiste ene mene
meck und du bist weg
also falsch heraus können nicht
rückwärts laufen
becker ich aus wie ein känguru die bald
heißt eine der kanalinsel nämlich würde
einfach sagen komm ich habe überhaupt
keine ahnung davon ein rechter winkel
sind genau 100 also so beschissen bin
ich in mathe jetzt auch wieder nicht
eine spinne hat acht bei dicker denkt
diese website wirklich wenn ich eine
spinne sehe ich erst mal ihre beine wie
wird man dabei direkt getötet bist du
ein mann oder eine frau war
das ist der richtige war oder
falschaussage
ich habe 15 von 20 richtig
tk
ich dachte ich wäre viel
an der stelle wird das heutige jetzt
allerdings auch verwenden meine damen
und herren heute mal an etwas kürzeres
video weil morgen ihr seht werde wieder
eingeblendet morgen um 15 uhr erscheint
im luca - shop.de meine neue kollektion
klamotten und deswegen müssen wir heute
noch ein paar sachen vorbereiten heute
ist auch ein timer auf die website
gekommen als ihr könnt ihr haben
wenn euch das hier trotzdem irgendwie
gefallen hat dann halt s maul